that's right Nazi you're not pulling any
punches with your opening preparation
you try D4 C5 against Alice Lee a very
enterprising approach now you started
off with the touch how did you come up
with this idea were you trying to put as
much pressure with the black pieces
early on uh yes and actually I got lucky
again with the preparation I predicted
she was gonna play Knight F3 even though
she plays E4 D4 C4 Knight F3 like all of
them so instead of preparing for
everything I only prepared against
Knight F3 and then she played it so it
worked out I think I got a decent
position I'm not sure if I played it all
correctly but
even though like I guess the prep I'm
not used to playing this so I definitely
wasn't sure that
what I was doing was all correct and it
seemed like it was
pretty correct right I mean you both
were playing good moves at this point
just her expanding on the queen side you
trying to get an attack going on the
king side was that the plan or were you
trying to strike in the center I was
hoping for eventually playing G5 and F4
as
but it got pretty
coincide she gave me
some tactical Chances with that B5 move
that I played yes that was a very nice
move and she did have this idea of
sacrificing the queen did you see I saw
it and I was afraid of it because
she only has a rook and a pawn or two
for it
but I couldn't evaluate this position at
all and I think if this was second game
where she needed a win she would have
definitely got it yes yeah after she
played this move Knight to B2 it just
felt like you're getting too much play
on this after this how much
and it was this big moment after d takes
C5 nicely spotted this queen takes D2
were you anticipating this when you
played the move Rook to A3 uh no
sir Presence at that I
C4 I played through K3 because when I
first calculated it after d takes C I
didn't say queen E2
so I was gonna play something else and
then I double checked one back to Rook
A3 and immediately spotted Queen D2
and then I thought there's no way she's
gonna take on C5 so I was expecting
Queen C2
and here I can just take Queen takes D4
and I don't know what she's gonna do
with the Knight on B2 probably go back
to A4 and I'm just much better I just
have to be careful about the C6 Pawn but
for a moment at least that promotion
square is pretty much guarded uh very
nicely by the Knight only seven and the
beach 26. that was game one and after
that in game two it felt like you were
able to neutralize any sort of counter
play from her side it felt very smooth
how would you assess yeah I was actually
surprised by her opening choice I
thought she was gonna play something
more aggressive since she needed a win
my guess is she may be prepared uh
against the game I played against Anna
where I played six move Queen C2 so this
time I changed it up and played Knight
C3 and I think I was never worse and at
the very end I think she just plundered
the queen or she would have taken the
tour of course yeah absolutely Nazi
congratulations you're going to be
waiting for either Irina or Alice Lee
actually let's go to that end game yes
or maybe we can pull it on your shirt
board and ask for Nazi's opinion on it
the last few moves were actually here
Rook C7 by Arena so she wanted to come
Rook Shack and invade either with a
Rooker or King so after Rook C7 A5 ba5
Rook A4 were up to date with the players
how do you feel uh black chances to get
the victory in this one hour so Irina is
the only one pressing right and she has
a huge time Advantage yes I would say
she has a chance
and how would you go about it Rook to D7
or
maybe Rook to D7 try to go with D3
because Rook D3 if I can get my king on
G4 then that's much better
right so you want to put the king all
the way to H3 yes sir
yeah so that you could get something
like this
this is getting Rook takes itself Maybe
King F1
I think it takes a four maybe
this does look good for black yeah yeah
yeah
no it looks like black if
she manages to take that pawn on E5 this
is not looking promising
plus with only one minute on the clock
for white
definitely easy to make a mistake
absolutely well still this one is still
ongoing Alice is still fighting for a
draw Nazi congratulations we'll see you
tomorrow thank you thank you our
congratulations as well uh very very
nicely played